(rock music)
(rewinding)
- I would never invite work
friends to a birthday party.
- Oh, I will take an open bar any day.
- Work. Pleasure. Bad combo.
- No, no it's not! Look!
Work.
Pleasure.
- Oh!
It's a fiesta-bomb. You want some?
- It's 7:30 on a Tuesday!
- Oh, live a little.
- I can't show you guys the real me.
Look at Kalen.
- Uh, is this guy bothering you?
- No.
- Oh, OK. Hey! Is that guy bothering you?
- Yeah, that's his move.
- That can't possibly ever work.
- Ah, probability, man.
- Well, I don't wanna know
what my drunk pick up line is.
- You don't have to go crazy or anything.
Uh, by the way, this is number five.
(inaudible chatting)
I mean, at least he's meeting people.
- I bet he's asking her what her sign is.
- So, it turns out, if you drill a hole
through the centre of a hotdog
and then replace the core with
some even lower quality meat,
consumers can't even tell the difference.
- I had no idea a business consultant
would know so much about meat.
- Oh, well, we consultants are ready
to handle any consumer needs.
- I can just picture you out
there on the factory floor
walking around in those cloud shoes.
- What, like, sanitary boots?
- Yeah, gotta get me some of them booties.
- What is it you do?
- I'm not really sure.
- If I was ready to meet someone,
I wouldn't just pick 'em up at a bar.
- But you're not meeting anyone anywhere.
- I did online.
That way, I know exactly
what I'm gonna get.
- Wow. That is a real celebration
of life's serendipity.
- It's like having a
baseball card of the person
before you even meet them.
- Oh god.
- That's incredible!
- It was the best.
- Hey!
- Hi.
- Is this guy bothering you? Er...
- No.
Anyway, so these statues are so frail...
- 'Cause he's bothering me.
- Is he actually bothering you?
- No. No, I'll handle it.
- You talking about
statues? I love statues!
They're like paintings, but more.
- OK, um, we're trying
to have a conversation,
can you stop bothering us?
- Rude.
- Harper, Harper, Harper?
- Uh huh? What?
- If I came up to you in a
bar, would you pick up on me?
- Come on, ah, I know too much about you
at this point to answer that honestly.
- Is that bad?
- I mean, like it's, I
know you're a hard worker
and you're very driven,
competent, dependable.
You're like a Golden Retriever.
- Don't people want that?
- Honey, you just don't
seem like you'd put out.
- What? I would totally put out.
- Oh, yeah?
- Bartender! Get me a
'tequila de los martos.'
- She means a fiesta-bomb.
- A fiesta-bomb, please.
You'll see!
- You don't have to do this.
- Bomb's away.
Watch this.
Hey.
- Hey.
- One fiesta-bomb for this sailor.
- That's really nice of you, but...
- Hey, are you interested in putting out?
I put out all the time.
- Listen, it's been a long day.
I'm just trying have a drink...
- It's OK, you can tell me.
- ...here, hey!
- Is this guy bothering you, Ana?
- Yes, yes he is.
- Hey man, why don't you beat it?
- Gladly.
- That is the nicest thing
anyone has ever done for me.
- It's like the nicest thing
I've ever done for anyone.
(loud rock music)
- [Kalen] You remind me
of this lady I work with.
I left my wallet at home.
Could you get these for me?
(spinning film reel)